[Music]
welcome to our 2022 lab roots webinar
series my name is tara niles regional
marketing development manager for the
life sciences electron microscopy team
from thermo fisher scientific and your
host today
we welcome back our returning attendees
and we send a big hello to our new
attendees wherever you are in the world
we are pleased to have two very engaging
speakers lined up for our session today
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
now let me introduce our speakers
melissa chambers is a director of the
center for structural biology cryo-em
facility at vanderbilt university
melissa has 15 years of experience using
cryo-em as a tool for investigating
structural and functional organization
of protein complexes
she has managed four facilities
including two at harvard medical school
and trained 200 plus researchers in
molecular electron microscopy
applications
while her primary expertise lies in
single particle analysis she is eager to
explore the emerging techniques of
institute cryo cryo electron tomography
and microwedding
and aid researchers in applying these in
fields beyond structural biology
every day melissa works to help others
understand the challenging topics and
master difficult skills in cryoam
certainly a noble effort and endeavor
and also with us is dr natalia duvall
who is a biochemist and protein
engineering specialist with more than 15
years experience in single particle
cryoelectron microscopy as well as
immunogenic design efforts for vaccine
achievement
she completed her master's in
biochemistry from the university of
zaragoza in spain and she received her
doctoral degree in biochemistry from the
university of leuven belgium
in october of 2017 she joined nci as the
director of the electron microscopy
laboratory and the team lead for cryo
electron microscopy section at the
center for molecular microscopy
she was responsible for the management
of a wide portfolio of projects related
mainly to cancer and hiv diseases
she has authored over 70 scientific
publications and in high impact
scientific journals such as science and
nature
she joined thermo fisher scientific in
january 2021 as a senior scientist
senior product specialist for electron
microscopy
in her current position she is
supporting electron microscopy in the
east coast and midwest of the usa
in the first part of today's session
melissa will share more information on
how cryo-em is being used to gain
important insights into fields such as
structural biology biochemistry and
structure-based drug design and also
share her experiences on how anyone can
get started
in the second portion of this event
natalia will give us details on the
factors to consider in instrumentation
for a new facility
and now we're ready to learn more from
our speakers melissa over to you for
your presentation
thank you tara i'm excited to kick off
the first of the series getting started
in cryolean with a talk today on recent
discoveries in structural biology
biochemistry and cell biology
trillium
is a method for investigating biological
structures and utilizing cryo et and
cryolium that can
provide a wide range of resolution
information all the way down close to
one angstrom
this is used to investigate how
molecular machines work drugs find
targets proteins interact and complex
complexes integrate in a cellular
context
vitrification allows for imaging samples
in the near native state the process of
vitrification happens when a aqueous
sample is frozen so quickly that ice
crystals do not form
and it allows us to image it in the
transmission electron microscope without
limiting the resolution of the sample
computational methods are then used to
reconstruct this into three dimensions
to learn
a variety of information
about purified proteins biomolecules or
cells
the main limitation for this method is
that samples smaller than 100 daltons of
molecular weight are challenging but not
impossible
this allows us to study a variety of
samples such as membrane ground proteins
and insoluble proteins
large viruses liposomes super molecular
complexes and even small enzymes and
nucleic acids
the popularity of cryo-em as a method
for studying protein structure has grown
according to unique structures deposited
in the protein data bank in 1991 there
was only one
unique structure deposited that year and
last year there were almost three
thousand
so highlighting some of the recent
discoveries
we're going to start with this
calcium-activated chloride channels
which are involved in the physiology of
the eye and are genetically linked to
retinal degenerative disorders and
progressive vision loss human best one
and best two were studied by this group
in multiple confirmations from an open
state in a partially open state and a
closed state and they were able to
determine these structures to the best
resolution of 1.8 ancients
this allowed this group to understand
how channel functions and to study
specific mutants
time resolved cryovm
aims to study processes on a millisecond
time scale
and looking at conformational changes
during assembly and disassembly of
protein complexes in this case this
group was looking at actimizing in
combination with atp
they used a microfluidic device to mix
the sample
just prior to spraying it on an em grid
and then immediately plunged into liquid
ethane for vitrification
and here they were able to follow this
process from seven milliseconds all the
way to 640 milliseconds
crying damn can be used in combination
with other structural and analytical
methods
while i mentioned that cryon has a main
limitation of
being more difficult to study uh
proteins with a lower molecular with a
molecular weight lower than 100
kilograms nmr is very well suited for
samples below 40 kilograms and so these
groups combined these two approaches to
study a large dodecameric enzyme tet2
which is 468 kilo dollars
this mixed approach allowed them to use
a 4.1 angstrom resolution cryo map
combined with nmr assignments from the
39 kilo dalton subunits to refine the
model to a resolution of one instrument
several groups including these groups
from university of oxford along with
thermo fisher scientific are working on
utilizing mass spectrometry to filter
the purified protein sample to apply
that high purity sample to the tmem grid
before vitrification
the hopes of this work is to make
high-resolution structure determination
by cryo-em more efficient by optimizing
the sample that's on the grid
some exciting work on how how cryovm can
be used to to investigate human health
the hips group at ut southwest medical
center investigated antibodies from an
encephalitis patient
and how these directly inhibited the
gaba a receptor function
one antibody directly competes with the
binding of neurotransmitters and another
antibody targeted the subunit interface
where compounds used to treat seizures
interact with the receptor these
identified residues and these antibodies
are involved in
specifically define the mechanism of
this autoimmune encephalitis
stepping away from purified protein
and looking
and and into this in situ work
which is where you can image complexes
in cells that have been vitrified in our
tem grid
here you can see that
cells were grown in a tm grid put into
an electron microscope and image
and some virus assembly is well
understood but this is not the case for
a family of alpha viruses chikungunya
virus is the most common alpha virus
that affects humans and there's no known
vaccine or antiviral available
so using cryoelectron tomography
infected human cells were vitrified
and imaged to determine structures of
viral and viral assembly intermediates
to inform inform how the spiral assembly
occurs in the cell and how the budding
can be blocked by antibiotics
another example of in-situ work combines
techniques from single particle analysis
with tomography and sub-tomogram
averaging
studying ribosome maturation
has large small units and small subunits
of the ribosome are synthesized
independently in the nucleolus before
being exported to the cytoplasm where
they assemble into functional organisms
and so in in this work of imaging the
nucleolus and identifying different
categories of
representative sub units
and it would find that the small sub
units did some subtomogram averaging in
this small subunit class averages
so a rearrangement of domains to become
more compact before it's being exported
to the cytoplasm
and this allowed the group to develop a
model
for ribosome maturation and how the
phase separation of the nucleolus
supports ribosomal biogenesis
as exciting as cryo-em is there's always
new developments and technologies coming
forward
this first one is from christopher says
group and they present a process for
manufacturing a new type of tem support
group that has small hexagonal holes
instead of the commonly used round holes
and they have shown that this reduces
specimen movement during imaging
which can
help improve high resolution information
and this method also
shows how you can produce
these bridges yourself in house with the
right equipment
corrado donna's group is developing
methods for making institute tomography
imaging more high throughput
ileum is the preferred technique for
studying complexes larger than 100
kilodalton and in in near native
conditions
samples can be purified proteins viruses
biomolecules and intact cells
studies can reveal how ions move across
membranes biological processes progress
with time viruses infect cells and
antibodies affect human health
and how our basic understanding of cell
biology may change as we study these
processes in native environments
there are always new innovations coming
out that are broadening the applications
of cryon and expanding the accessibility
to researchers
that's the end of this first section on
getting started
so in this section of getting started in
prior iem i'm gonna discuss some
workflow considerations
there are three main methods to reveal
structural information of biological
molecules the first is x-ray
crystallography
in this method samples must be
crystallized which means they're removed
from the native or experimental
environment
this step is not trivial and can take a
lot of time and effort
crystals reveals a static form of a
complex and it's not dynamic requires a
large amount of sample at high
concentrations and it can yield very
high resolution data
nmr is able to examine samples in an
aqueous solution in a near native state
it is good for starting dynamic and
flexible complexes
a large amount is required of 300
microliters or more
and if this is
while there are some
techniques that can study higher
molecular weight proteins in general a
small molecular weight of 40 kilograms
or less is ideal for mmr
the sample needs to be very pure and it
can yield high resolution data
so we're here to talk about pro-electron
microscopy today
and
the great things that this technique can
do so the step of vitrification of your
samples maintains your samples in a near
native an experimental state
it's suitable to investigate complexes
with multiple conformations and can
accommodate some amount of heterogeneity
and flexibility
you only need a small amount of sample
20 microliters of a one milligram per
milliliter concentration is enough to
repair several grids it can be difficult
to work with complexes lower than 100
kilo dollars but it is possible and
there are new techniques that are
pushing this one
it is possible to get below two angstrom
with ideal sample and optimization
while two to five two inch terms to five
angstroms is more common and also in
that range a lot of biological questions
can be answered
as exciting as primary ammos
biochemistry is still the most important
step in the process
size exclusion chromatography should be
one of your last steps of purification
in this project with herd one herd three
complex we had this nice peak that
gave us confidence that our
sample was vitamin c pure and
structurally homogeneous
you can see that here in this prior oem
image and the 2d class averages that
resulted from it
while some amount of flexibility and
conformational changes
can
be analyzed by uvm it's best to minimize
these if possible
it's rare that you need to change your
buffer from your experimental conditions
you do want to keep salt to a minimum as
that can have a high background in your
cryonium images
and minimize the amount of glycerol
preferably no glycerol at all i have
never had the luxury of being able to
work with a sample that i could purify
and then freeze to later fall and use
for prioem and often a fresh
purification needs to be performed
before vegetarian grids to ensure
stability and homogeneity of your
complex
negative stain analysis
can really help with your assessment of
your sample for crying it's excellent
for informing the suitability
based on oligomerization state domain
organization binding sites
this can help you ensure that your
particles are homogeneous in size shape
and conformation
this can also help you change buffer
conditions or purification conditions to
reduce aggregation heterogeneity
degradation or perhaps using
a component in the buffer
that leaves our effects
and this is a quick and efficient way of
spring and purification conditions and
buffer components
so here's an ideal image of protein
complexes and negative stain
you see a very similar size and shape of
these complexes but beyond just a single
image you can do some 2d classification
that can reveal more information
the resolution here is limited to about
18 instruments but it can help provide
quantitative evidence for
homogeneity and suitability for
continuing with prion
here we see
a top view of the complex and a side
view
if this isn't the case
and you don't have nice 2d class
averages this is the chance to back up
change your experimental parameters and
repeat
a lot of work up front on your
purification and optimizing your sample
before going into cryogam is going to
save you a lot of effort down the road
i want to show some examples of how the
same particle can look under different
conditions so this is the image a
negative sane image of the proteasome
about 750 kilo dalton so it's a large
complex
there's an image
of it in vitrified ice
not as high contrast but you can still
see these complexes and they're nicely
dispersed
and then in an in-situ environment so
this is in a whole cell that has been
vitrified and you see these proteasome
complexes in their native state
you can see some indicated by these
yellow area arrows you have side views
you have top views
and a little more detail
you can see them here so it's really
fascinating the scale that you can look
at these complexes from
when it comes to vitrification there are
some considerations to think of while
this can preserve your sample in a near
native condition with no artifacts from
a stain and no limit to your resolution
it also is low contrast and can be
tedious and not always reproducible when
you're first starting
so here we have a cryo-em grid it has a
metal support mesh and on top of that
mesh is a holy film
and in these holes
you can see the side view here this is
where your vitrified ice will be that'll
have your particles in it
so there are a variety of grids and
substrates to use
the metal support mesh here can be
copper or gold
there's a range of mesh size from 300
from 200 to 400
while 400 is very robust and easy to
handle it has smaller areas for imaging
and on the opposite end 200 has very
large squares for imaging so that can
increase your exposure rate when you're
collecting data can also be very fragile
so a 300 mesh
300 support mesh is a good compromise
the holy film on top can also be made of
carbon or gold there's evidence out
there that
using gold both the support mesh and the
film can
reduce specimen movement during imaging
there's also graphene oxide support that
can be laid over on top of this film
that
provides support for your samples to
encourage them to to get into the holes
of ice
and be here this is
ideally what you want on the side view
you can see you have particles and
random orientations fully embedded in
the ice
c and d have particles on the surface of
the ice and that's called the air water
interface and that can either induce
preferred orientation such as in c
or even damage the particles in d
in figure e
and g
these are both
these are
these both can be assessed with some
negative stain so in e you have
degradation of the complex falling apart
and then g you have aggregation
and doing a lot of work with negative
stain may help prevent this from
happening
in f this is where your particles prefer
to stick to the carbon instead of being
embedded in the ice
a way to get around this is to maybe try
gold film or even a graphene oxide
support
vitrification is the bottleneck of this
workflow
you can
suggest my suggestion is to plan your
vitrification steps very well to make
each attempt more successful
follow your
your processes in the same order try to
have the same timing between steps so
that everything can be more produceable
when you do it again
your goal is the thinnest size or you
can still visualize your particles
and this may not be the same for every
sample you look at
because everything is completely a
little different
several rounds of screening preparing
more grids doing some cryo-em screening
processing some data going back that is
not uncommon
in the end
it may only be one grid that you need to
have enough areas to collect images to
get your high resolution information
there's a lot of
innovation in this area with new grid
types new manufacturing homemade
vitrification devices
so i there's going to be a lot of
movement in the area of vitrification in
the future
so some key points i want you to take on
that biochemistry is the most important
step
all the optimization of your sample
before moving on to vitrification is
very important and it will pay off
destructification is the bottleneck of
this workflow and it will take a lot of
effort be open to embracing new
innovations and new technologies that
will help
there are a lot of resources out there
but if i could point you to one place it
would be
cryovmcenters.org which is the nih's
national facilities for cryo-em prior et
and curriculum development
they have excellent courses to follow
and
information to help you get started
the 3d em mailing list could be
considered a community resource
where it's a great place for you to ask
questions of people in the field
stay up to date on topics learn about
meetings and workshops and even job
postings and
finally there's a collection of bad
cryo-em images from the electron
microscopy center at new york structural
biology center
these images are categorized and so as
you are struggling to get very nice
petrified ice or good images
you can
look at the images there see if you can
help diagnose
what's going on with your samples and
some suggestions to fix
that's the end of the section and i'm
going to pass it on to natalia he's
going to talk about infrastructure and
instrumentation to help you get started
thank you
so thank you melissa for that amazing
presentation highlighting all the
beauties of cryogen
so before i start
my presentation i would like to again uh
you know explain very quickly how
cryogen is becoming a very important
technique for structural biology studies
and is the fattest fastest growing
structural biology method for
characterizing proteins and pathogens
and it's very important because as you
know the human body contains between 80k
and 400k proteins so
being able to understand how this
protein interacts with each other are
essential for you know understanding
diseases and being able to develop new
therapies
so this is an example of how crayon was
very very important and key for three
different diseases the first one i want
to highlight today is the new patty that
was discovered in the mrc lab by the uk
people so we were able to use in cryo-em
to really understand and discover a new
disease in this case the
tlnt
for alzheimer's so
thanks to crayon we were able to
understand better this kind of a
diseases similar uh with ebola and using
crayon we were able to discover two new
antibodies that they were able to bind
to two uh ebola viruses the ebola one
and the sudan one and this is uh are the
the biggest and this is outbreaks uh a
viruses so this is very very important
to understand how we can target these
viruses and finally you know cryogenian
is helping a lot to understand as well
cancer formation so this work was going
to stand for and we were able to for the
first time get a cryo-en sculpture of
this a kindness uh uh enzyme and it was
very important because we are able to
see
how we can target this enzyme to develop
new therapies
with that being said you already know
you know how important cryogen is and i
i want to highlight some of the
main uh you know i will say
a state of the art uh like we were able
to obtain with cryogen so the first one
you can see here in your left is the
vessel resolution
in 2020
the first atomic resolution coming from
single particle analysis was done at
1.22 astronomers this is apophagin and
you can see water molecules so oxygen
and hydrogen atoms so it's very
impressive because you know i never
thought when i started doing cryo
electron microscopy over 15 years ago
like i will be able to see this kind of
atomic resolution maps coming from cryon
so it's very impressive obviously we
were able to analyze the largest viral
protein over 10.1 mega dollars for this
poliovirus type 1
doing cryogen and this was done by
cryotomography and the resolution was
2.9 angstroms and obviously we were able
to or as well obtain the smallest
protein like around 40 kilowatt on like
four trio en single particle standards
is very very small
a 3.7 ounce clones so again only to give
you an idea how important cryo-em is and
is even becoming more and more essential
uh to do cryogen if you want to analyze
your a protein or complex of interest
and have structural biology information
so again some people still think uh like
uh crayon
is you know a very difficult technology
it's a complex technology it's still
very expensive
and it's difficult to access and
difficult to use but i'm hoping with
this seminar series you will be able to
get the point like it's not the case
anymore uh we are trying to make this
technique as affordable as possible to
open trioem to other people to many many
labs uh we are trying to
integrate artificial intelligence and
material learning like can make the use
of the microscopes much easier and
obviously uh we are trying to provide as
many trainings and workshops
hands-on as possible like people can you
know understand the technique and come
become
experts in cryogenia
so this is a tiny video like uh i want
to show you very uh you know quickly uh
the differences in between the two main
crayon techniques
one is single particle analysis so from
proteins in solution to atomic model is
exceeded ethnic so you have your protein
of interest expressed and purified you
abilify the protein of interest into the
cryo-encrypt and you load that cryo-end
grid into your tem microscope and this
is a typical image you will be able to
obtain under cryogen conditions so a
computationally while the data is
collected you will be able to pick up
single particles
in different orientations so you will be
able to get bottom views side views and
in between of your particle of interest
so the more
orientations you will be able to get of
your protein the better because you will
be able to
create and generate the thing that we
call the 2d projections or 2d classes
like they are projections of your
particle of interest and again
computationally you will be able to
extract the information you need from
those 2d projections to generate at the
end the 3d reconstruction of your
protein
so uh this is the typical xc to work for
single particle analysis and as i said
before with the new cameras the new
hardware we really can reach atomic
resolutions almost on regular basis
sample dependent
so this is the typical um you know
workflow that you will be able to get
sample preparation data collection and
3d reconstruction and i will explain
later on during my presentation all the
instrumentations and all the materials
that you will need to think to be able
to
do a single particle analysis in your
lab
cryotomography is being able to see
protein
in cells and tissues so it's in c to
work and uh in this particular video i
would like to show you a tiny bit how it
works mostly focusing on viruses so you
have your virus of interest and you will
be able to beautify these virus in your
cryo-end grid and after that when the
virus is in the grid you will be able to
load that grid into the tl microscope
the main difference in between
cryotomography and single particle or
one of the main difference is the way
you call it data so for single particle
you don't do any tilt for cryotomography
you are doing a tilt series so you are
collecting data in between minus 60
minus 70 to plus 60 plus 70 degrees so
you are generating this tomogram like we
call it's like a movie where you put
together all the teal series to create
the tomogram of the virus or the
tomorrow of the cell and protein of
interest in situ
so again computationally once this
tomogram is collected you will be able
to do analysis on the tomogram and we
can call this tomogram and subtomorrow
ability where you will be able to do as
well some segmentation work to obtain
the 3d volume of your final virus so the
resolution is different you can get
atomic resolutions with single particle
you can get around nanometer resolutions
with tomography
but the beauty of tomography is like is
it work in situ so you can really
understand you know how the proteins are
interacting with other proteins in the
context of the cell so the the process
and the pipeline for tomography is a bit
different like with for single particle
analysis so the first stage will be
beautification of the cells or the virus
of interest and you can do some
correlative microscopy as well so you
can target and a level the protein of
interest with a fluorophore and you can
localize that with a external uh clean
system and you can go to the focus ion
beam
to do a
lamella so that means you can open cells
or you can open a windows into the cell
so you will be able to create the
lamella they are very thin
in between 150 and 250 nanometers to
literally load those lamellas into the
transmission electron microscope to
start collecting data in the cell and
why we need to do uh the focus ion beam
and when you are working with cells this
is very important step because otherwise
the cells are too thick and if you grow
the cell directly into the cryogen grid
and you transfer that grade directly
into the transmission electron
microscope you won't be able to see
anything because it's too thick so
that's the reason you need to open those
windows in the cell to be able to see
all the organelles and all the proteins
interest internally in the cell directly
by transmission electron microscope so
this step is very important for
tomography and it's not necessary for
single particle analysis
so the single particle analysis workflow
i have uh you know several steps here
and i want to highlight first
how uh term officer is really working
very very very hard
to do the full pipeline for single
particle analysis as easy and as
affordable as possible for even novice
people like they are no expert yet in
cryogen
so the first step obviously is always
sample purification so a thermofisher is
here as well to help you uh in that step
uh you have different uh you know
machines different instrumentations like
we need you will need to purchase to be
able to express and purify the protein
of interest and i highlight some
examples here for example the
electrophoresis systems they get
imagined system
the gel uh hank and spondell all the you
know fplc splc
machines to be able to purify the
proteins and obviously all the pipettes
and micropipettes to do all that
the second step obviously one the sample
is already purified is gonna be the
sample quality control and that can be
done uh very easily with transmission
electron microscopes like can be the
side entry holders like the talos 120c
or the thalos 200 or can be the new
entry level a single particle analysis
microscope or new tundra at 100k
so uh you will be able to estress purify
your sample and put the sample in a
cryo-end grid or an artist in grid room
temperature first
screen the quality of the sample so that
means if the sample is homogeneous if
the sample is heterogeneous it is
aggregating and using those microscopes
while the sample is good uh by roon
temperature standards you will be able
to do the beautification process and for
that you will be able to use the
petrobot a coming from thermofister as
well
so it's a very easy machine for
beautification purposes and again you
will need as well different tweezers
different pipettes and as well as a you
know cryo em storage dewars
so once you have your sample uh
beautified you will need to be able to
store uh those samples and again using
different devices and the words for
example storage
and finally you will be able to use the
glacios and the cryos the very high
level ten microscopes to be able to do
data analysis and data collection and
obviously when data is collected after
using the glaciers and the
cryos you need to transfer the data into
a cluster where you will be able to do
all the data processing using
cryosphere and other programs for single
particle analysis
so again sample purification process
sample quality control mostly for roon
temperature negative single particle
analysis
once the the control is good and you
will do the vitrification the bit robot
and the storage and visualization uh in
the glacious cryos and data analysis
so i put together a table several tables
i will say uh with highlighting the main
instrumentation that you will need to
establish a electromicroscopy lab and
this is the general instrumentation like
you will need for single particle as
well as for tomography analysis or
studies so uh
here in the column here in the
left you can see the device in the
middle you can see the purpose and
obviously the supplier like we recommend
so the first thing obviously you will
need to have is a microscope and i
didn't even add that into this table
because it's obvious you will need to
have a transmission electron microscope
you can get one for screening and
optimization and the same one for data
collection or if you are lucky enough
and you have you know the capability
enough you will get two you will get one
entry-level microscope for screening and
optimization purposes and a second
microscope can be a glacious can be a
cryos for data collection for high
resolution data collection and for
tomography data collection as well so
that's obvious but
plus a
except for the microscope like obviously
you you need that you will need to have
a bit robot uh that's for a
beautification of the grids and uh you
will need to have a plasma cleaner or
clothing charger like it's very
important to provide hydrophilicity of
ian grits to optimize the distribution
of the particles on ice
you will need to have a carbon
evaporator as well this is can be
optional but we highly recommend that
for providing an additional carbon layer
into the mostly the negative stain en
grids for a screening and optimization
of your samples
you will need a polarization optical
microscope
for answering that the auto grids are
properly clipped into the auto leather
cartilage
you will need to have several viewers
the first they were four liters ones
they are for easy nitrogen pouring when
you are beatifying the grits and the
very big ones the 120 liters tank those
are for liquid nitrogen storage uh so
you will need to have those for storage
and for pulling nitrogen and you will
have to get access to a cabinet for
eaton
including installation and connection to
the exhaust this is very very important
because for safety reasons you need to
have the eaton uh in that in that
cabinet or a data can be as well stored
under the chemical hood you will need to
buy heat and gas cylinders uh and this
is a we need to eat for vitrification
purposes so i usually would recommend
eating a cylinder of 20 liters but you
can decide which one you want to buy
um obviously you need to have a storage
dwarf a tailor a hc-35
and this is for long-term storage of
beautified grids
once the grids with the sample of
interest are bigly fired you can store
them for months or even longer if you
want
a before data a collection in the
microscope but for that you need a
specific um you know a d1 like it's very
very big for data storage
the grid storage system obviously you
need to store the grids in a very
organized way so we recommend this
system like they are very compatible
with the hc35
and obviously they restorate a pock like
they are very convenient to store those
grits in a very very organized way
and you have a need for a fonditus
transfer those petrified grates into the
box
you will need as well
the tyler worth on dry zipper if you
want to ship the grits to other
facilities for example some cases you
have in your lab a screening microscope
to optimize and to screen the grids but
you don't have uh you know the cryos or
the glaciers to collect data so you need
to ship those creeds to other national
centers so this will be very useful for
that you will need a digital dry bath
you know with blow heater this is very
convenient for dry cryotools during the
clipping and the loading of the grids
obviously you need pipettes and a drying
cabinet to accelerate the drying process
for a small tooling and all those
accessories here i don't want to go one
by one through them but this will be
provided by thermal once you have the
microscope delivery and they are totally
necessary for clipping the grids and
prepare the grids to go with the
glaciers the tundra or the cryos
the last thing obviously more
consumables you need to think always
about the consumables like they will be
very important to run the microscopes
and
as well you know processing pc so
obviously i explain a lot uh all the
materials that you will need to prepare
the sample to prepare uh you know and
purify the the protein to uh you know
screen the samples in different
microscopes but and how to call it data
collection but the only thing you don't
want to forget is that you need to
process all the data you are collecting
and for that you need to have a specific
pc
for doing all the data processing
and in that regard uh
you need to be able uh to head
some linux box stations uh like they are
all can be individual for your lab but
you will need as well to have a access
to the cluster in your institution you
know like you will be able to
not only process the data in the cluster
with different uh softwares like
reliable cryospat but as well being able
to storage those uh data because they
are very big in the archiving area of
the cluster so this is something that
you need to keep in mind you need to be
able to have access to a big cluster to
process the data and storage the data
and even using global's other system to
transfer data to collaborators as well
so
being careful that you need to be
to have some kind of very itid support
this is very important obviously you
need a staff to be able to run the
microscopes to be able to uh prepare the
samples for screening and optimization
of the samples and obviously you need to
have some id person uh or have some
contact with it person in your
institution like can help you
with data transfer and data processing
as well
and we have obviously term officer is
here to help you as much as we can
so we have
a application or apps an online system
so you can get over 50 hours of single
particle analysis workflow education we
are working as well on putting cryo t
workflow as well in this website and you
can get uh cryo-em school access uh
in-depth forty casting excellence and
you can even get a certificate of
completion after that and we have some
customers here uh a testimonial they are
very very happy with this uh you know
system obviously uh we encourage you to
please join our cryogen learning
community today
don't delay this because you will be
able to get access to webinars podcasts
videos questions announcers even ask the
experts sessions
and
reach out to the go online term
officer.com cryogen and you will be able
to find all these things to be able to
learn even more what needs to be done uh
to establish a lab
and with that i would like to thank you
for your
attention and your time today and please
don't hesitate if you have any
suggestions to reach out to me this is
my email address natalya.com
thank you so much
wonderful fantastic presentations
melissa and natalya thank you so much uh
really a lot of valuable and practical
information to help people get started
on their journey through prioem uh it's
great to see all of these tips and uh
valuable content
um now it's time for our question and
answer session and i'll remind the
audience to please type in your
questions and click submit we already
have uh some really good questions
coming through we've got a fantastic
audience of various user levels um so i
will go ahead and start the first
question
um let's see
this question is for you melissa
about how long does it take to get
familiar with uh the sample preparation
processes
well i think one thing about this
technique is that you get out of it what
you put in so if you
spend a lot of effort
attempting to handle handling these
grids
working with the vitrification process
making sure you have a nice protocol
that you can consistently follow every
time
that will
go very far and benefit you um
oftentimes
for projects like this someone may
you know spend a lot of effort get good
grids then they may spend six months or
more collecting data processing data and
then when they're ready to come back to
it it can be some time so it's always
good to have a really nice protocol
written out that you can come back to um
but the more experience you have
handling grids and vitrifying grids and
screening them to get feedback on the
vitrification conditions the
to do it more reproducibly
excellent thank you
and uh maybe this one is a good one for
you natalia um what type of training
support is included when you purchase a
microscope
okay that's a very good question and
there is no state for one answer uh you
know depending we have different uh i
would say programs different uh package
and you can purchase with the instrument
uh so depending of your expertise uh
we will recommend you to purchase one or
another
so you can totally decide how many hours
it's very flexible all these packages
are very flexible for example in one
package they say package a it comes with
30 hours of cleaning and this can be on
site signing with or
you know application scientists
especially or this can be a virtual
training as well so
once you are done with the 30 hours of
training and you don't feel still
confident
enough to use the microscope by yourself
you can always request to have more
claiming sessions and again uh we have
as well
a support uh like it's a virtual support
like it's 24 7 so if you have any issues
with the microscope
or any problems with the software or you
know any question you can always reach
out to us
through that program and we can help you
so it's very again very flexible and
depending of your expertise we will
recommend you uh to purchase uh one uh
package or another package but we are
always here to help you i mean and
support you during your journey on
adopting
perfect thank you
all right and uh maybe here's one uh
maybe melissa if you'd like to start off
maybe natalia can also jump in uh after
so if during vitrification a complex
falls apart
what can be done to avoid it or to fix
it
melissa
so
the the first thing i would suggest is
and i mentioned this in my talk as well
check it by negative stain
right before you vitrify it even if this
is a purification you do frequently all
the time
you probably also know that sometimes
things can go wrong so make sure that
the protein is intact
before you vitrify it every time
if it's then still falling apart maybe
consider
some buffer conditions um if it's a
membrane
protein or you use different detergents
i've seen different detergents
work better for vitrification for some
complexes than others
you can try
if it's maybe sticking to the edges of
the grid holes you can you know if you
have
a carbon foil you can try something to
be with a gold foil
um
it could also be
potentially you maybe you need a little
bit thicker ice everybody wants to go
for really nice thin ice but sometimes
then ice can be too thin for your
samples
um so it can be just kind of varying not
only your your experimental conditions
your buffer conditions but maybe also
some of
the substrate grid substrates natalia do
you have anything to comment on that too
yeah no that's perfect i mean i think
you already touched every single point
another thing maybe i can add uh is
maybe try to to change um you know the
substrate even sometimes this can help
instead of using the typical carbon
grids you can use cold grits or maybe
some kind of affinity grids so there are
plenty right now in the market like they
can sometimes help with this kind of
problems and again it's not a magic
recipe depending on the sample you will
need to try different approaches but i
completely agree with melissa you know
those are the main things that you can
find with something is falling apart
wonderful very very good practical
information
really keeping avoiding those pitfalls
and getting closer to excellent data
okay the next question that we have is a
detailed question and uh maybe again
melissa if you'd like to start us off uh
great work
how will cryo-electron microscopy
help in teasing out the pathophys
physiology as well as therapeutic design
of neuropsychiatric disorders
namely autism spectrum disorders
dementia
obsessive-compulsive disorders and
schizophrenia and maybe let's let's
focus on the dementia group of disorders
abnormal and accumulation of proteins in
neurons so melissa how is cryo-em used
for neurodegenerative
applications
yeah those are some really great things
that
that can be investigated um there is a
shore shares group and natalya touched
on this in her presentation has done a
lot of work on assembly of tau filaments
um and looking at
mutants that are common in alzheimer's
disease and also
assembly similar to
chronic traumatic encephalopathy
um and so
there are groups that are working on
that specifically and that's more of a
of a single particle approach
um
in general looking at maybe if you're
looking at
different types of cell interactions
that can be something leading a little
more towards
using some cryo et and some in situ work
i know some groups that work on synaptic
vesicle release in neurons and neurons
are thin enough that you don't have to
to mill them with um the
fib
and so you can
grow those
cells on grids and and put them in the
tem and image them that way
but you could also look at different
cell types coming together or different
interactions in a cell
cell migrations and looking at
using the fib to thin those
perfect thank you
and natalia anything to add
uh no i think uh as melissa pointed out
already you know we have plenty of
examples of different investigators
working with this kind of diseases and
at the beginning a few years ago they
were very challenging to study uh you
know because they are filaments they can
be very random they can be quite
flexible i mean all the things like they
are very challenging for crystallography
for example or even for cryo single
particle analysis and right now
uh another thing like it's always very
impressive to me is like uh with the new
hardware the new cameras the new
software the way we analyze the data
even the way we prepare the samples you
know is getting there is helping us a
lot to be able to study this very
challenging uh you know diseases and as
medicine we have plenty of examples of
you know investigators doing that mostly
you know one of the ones that we
highlight during the talk today was
source uh in the uk like he's focusing
his lap in this kind of physicist and
it's very exciting to see how cryo ian
is helping uh you know cryotomographian
single particle in analyzing and
developing even new therapeutics for
these diseases so it's it's a perfect
moment will you know to jump into
cryogen if you really want to study this
kind of diseases that will be my
recommendation
perfect thank you both and
i'll just make sure that we highlight uh
please explore the resources tab where
you could find some of the links and web
pages that natalia and melissa just
referenced um on our web pages we've got
learning centers and we even have a
webinar of past
tau filament uh cryo-em exploration so
please make sure that you explore those
resources for additional
information the next question um natalia
let's uh let's have you start off with
how challenging is it to capture in
vitro dynamic processes such as
polymerization for example using cryo-em
yeah that's a very good question so
these kind of dynamic processes uh they
are still uh almost so they are very
difficult to do by crystallography for
example because we can in general think
is more like an aesthetic technique you
know so you have uh
usually one state of the protein that
you can crystallize and usually to do or
to have those crystals you probably need
to
do some kind of modifications in your
protein of interest so cryo and the
beauty mostly single particle for
example is that you can really work with
a very close native uh you know protein
states and you can even cast your
different conformations of the same
protein and again um we are developing
methods on how to even capture much more
small changes in the protein you know
like it's almost a
life visualization
and more and more apis and investigators
are trying to do this you know because
already by cryo yeah you can they enable
and one example is the abc transporters
for example you can get the close estate
100 you can get a 100 open state but you
have plenty of different conformations
and states in between open and close so
those can be totally be captured already
by cryogen single particle analysis and
it's very easy to do in the sense that
you can you know collect the data and do
the data processing and analysis and you
will be able directly in the 2d projects
also to the classes to see the
differences you know uh in between those
states and generate different 3d volumes
using those 2d projections with the
different states uh different people
as joachim frank in colombia and other
people are trying to develop techniques
to even capture and freeze in
nanoseconds you know a specific
conformation or for example an enzyme so
this can be already be done and it's
having more and more develop you know to
be able to cut through all those dynamic
processes you know the best we can again
task but it can be done
perfect thank you very much and we'll
just uh answer one last question in the
last minute or so uh does the tomography
need to be captured in real time or can
it be retrieved later
and can the image be rotated so just
have a one minute answer for that please
yeah i can go ahead uh so i would
probably say the tomography uh you know
you can do all the data collection of
the tomography life uh i mean once you
prepare for example the lamella on
yourself uh those lamela can be safe for
you know several weeks or months if you
want in liquid nitrogen before going
to the tm for data collection we highly
recommend uh to prepare the lamella and
the sooner you can to do the data
collection in the microscope to avoid
any ice contamination the lamella can be
quite fragile sometimes specific
specific specifically the thinner you
made the lamella the fragile the more
fragile they can be so once you have the
lamella for example you can go to the
tea and call it data they are and make
the tomograms and once you have the
tomograms you can do all the data
processing and that can be done wherever
you have the time so it can be live you
know you can call it data and directly
start doing some data processing in the
tomogram with the tv series or you can
call it the whole data and do the data
processing later on so thank you
yes great thank you very much
so before we go i'd like to thank
everybody for joining us today and for
all of the interesting questions the
questions that we did not have time for
today will be addressed via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration
all of this information as well as
others in our electron microscopy series
can be viewed on demand on lab routes we
encourage you to share this session with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
if you'd like to learn more about
getting started in cryogem please visit
our website to explore all of the
learning resources to support your
cryo-em endeavors you could find out
what's possible in this exciting field
or contact us here if you have
additional questions
i'd like to send a huge thank you to our
speakers melissa and natalia you shared
so much valuable information i hope this
uh really benefits people looking to get
started and they've got a good set of
references to help them along the way
and thank you to everybody who joined us
today and our organizers
until next time goodbye thank you
bye
you